mind your decisions presh tall Walker
here start with the circle draw a chord
and then draw another chord that makes a
30 degree angle with this court then
draw another chord that's 30 degrees
apart if the chord on the left has a
length of 10 and the chord on the right
has a length of 12 what is the length of
the chord in the middle whose value is X
I saw a similar problem on reddit
homework help pause the video if you'd
like to give it a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
we'll solve this problem by working in
steps first focus on this part of the
diagram this is a 30 degree inscribed
angle corresponding to this arc of the
circle if we have another inscribed
angle for the same arc it'll have the
same measure by the inscribed angle
theorem so this inscribed angle will be
30 degrees now we'll do a similar thing
for this inscribed angle it corresponds
to this arc of the circle
therefore this inscribed angle will also
measure 30 degrees now go back to the
diagram and focus on this isosceles
triangle the sides opposite the 30
degree angles will be equal to each
other and let's say each of them has a
value of y we'll go back to the original
diagram and now we can focus on just
this quadrilateral we'll break it down
into two different triangles for the
triangle on the right we can use
al-qasas law of cosines to get that Y
squared is equal to 12 squared plus x
squared minus 2 times 12 times X times
the cosine of 30 degrees we'll do a
similar thing for this triangle and we
get Y squared is equal to 10 squared
plus x squared minus 2 times 10 times x
times cosine of 30 degrees we now have a
system of two equations we'll subtract
the second equation from the first the Y
squared terms will cancel out and x
squared terms will cancel out so we're
left with 0 is equal to 12 squared minus
10 squared and then we have to be
careful here we have negative 24x cosine
of 30 degrees minus a negative so
that'll become a positive 20 X cosine of
30 degrees so that results in negative 4
X cosine of 30 degrees we now solve this
equation we rearrange the equation and
then solve for X and that simplifies to
be 22 divided by the square root of 3
and that's our answer and if we go back
to the original diagram there's another
way that we can write it X is equal to
the simple average of 10 and 12 divided
by the code
sign of 30 degrees in fact we can
generalize this formula suppose we have
a valid diagram with chords of a and B
and this angle is equal to theta you can
actually prove using the same method in
this video that X is equal to the simple
average of a and B divided by the cosine
of theta the middle chord is the simple
average or arithmetic mean multiplied by
an adjustment factor of 1 over the
cosine of theta it's like we've
discovered a new type of average of how
cord lengths progress in a circle it's
not technically new because someone
probably will have discovered it
thousands of years ago but it was new to
me and that's the joy of discovery in
mathematics thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]